gayraud chez merci nous accueillir chez
vous alors on va parler évidemment ne
pas gérer la joie qu'est ce que vous
retenez de l'homme tout d'abord je
dirais c'est sa constance dans la foi en
éducation
c'était un homme qui avait des idéaux
qui avait des principes qu'il y avait
des bus qui avait un grand sens de la
justice sociale mais qui en même temps
ce avec eux il fallait prendre des
moyens pour réaliser des chefs opérer
des changements par le biais de sa
réforme en éducation dit de paul gérin
lajoie qu'il a aussi contribué à
l'émancipation de deux jeunes d'une
génération de plusieurs générations de
femmes donc c'est un avant gardiste
finalement aussi oui oui de plus humain
vous avez ce que pas de gérer la joie
fait c'est de transformer de québec au
fond par le système d'éducation et que
dès 1960 paul gérin lajoie bien compris
que la graine la grande majorité des
québécois de langue française était sous
scolarisés que la grande majorité des
québécois de la langue française n'avait
pas fait plus que l'école primaire cela
était gravement dangereux pour
l'économie du québec et aussi bien sûr
qu'il y avait un problème de justice
sociale à m il y avait des deux mais
nous nous engagions après la guerre dans
une nouvelle une nouvelle ère
industrielle d'une nouvelle ère du monde
du travail et la majorité des québécois
n'étaient pas prêts à cela il fallait
donc agir rapidement est ce que pas que
j'aurai la joie fait de génial
dès 1942 1962 c'était de d'ouvrir
l'enseignement secondaire à tout le
monde de créer ce qui a plaidé
commission scolaire régionale et c'est
comme si je suis allée régionales avec
metz possibilité de créer des écoles
secondaires publiques gratuites ce que
l'on a appelé par la suite des
polyvalentes et sas a permis la à des
jeunes filles et des garçons d'entrer
dans le système dans des systèmes
publics de s'instruire
et d'aller par la suite à l'université
au cégep au collégial c'est la grande
transformation évidemment cela a
favorisé des garçons de milieux
défavorisés qui n'aurait pas connu les
cela et ça surtout favoriser les fixes
et donc c'est aussi à ce moment là
évidemment que l'école a été rendue
obligatoire à partir de jusqu'à l'âge de
16 ans et quand on parle de réformes guy
rocher réforme
ça s'est passé facilement et de
l'opposition comment at il pu surmonter
les obstacles dans les années 60 et
réformer tout système d'éducation c'est
quand même quelque chose en créer un
ministère de l'éducation on met dehors
tous les évêques qui était qui avait
l'autorité sur le système public elle
des 22 élèves du québec avec toute
autorité sur le système public et du
coup enfreint le mystère de situation il
perdait tout cela c'était loin d'être
facile de la faire accepter un don qui a
fallu négocier il a fallu que paul gérin
lajoie le premier ministre lui-même de
jean lesage négocié avec les évêques et
chic évidemment changé la donne
c'était que le l'état québécois à partir
de ce moment là sous l'impulsion de paul
gérin lajoie l'état québécois
investissait financement finale
financiers allemands dans l'éducation
parce que jusqu'en 1960 l'état ait été
chiche à l'endroit de l'éducation mais
voilà que là on ouvrait les coffres de
deux des fonds publics
et même on en venait à accepter l'idée
de la gratuité jusqu'à l'université
donc ça c'était évidemment un grand
changement
il y avait sa fondation par la suite et
donc il a il est très connu il a fait
beaucoup pour le québec mais il a fait
aussi beaucoup ailleurs en afrique
notamment par le biais de sa fondation
oui tout d'abord à 20 sa fondation
pendant plusieurs années il a dirigé ce
qui s'appelait l' agence canadienne de
développement et l
ça c'était important dans la vie de paul
gérin lajoie parce qu'anna c'est à ce
moment là que pas que j'allais la joie
est entrée sur la scène internationale
et c'est à ce moment là que pas de gêne
à la joie pris conscience du problème de
l'éducation dans le monde et ça c'était
la transition pour lui je pense entre le
québec
donc s'ils s'étaient occupés plus
l'international et c'est en quittant
l'acdi qu'il a décidé de créer sa
fondation paul gérin lajoie qui allait
poursuivre au fond de travail d' el
hadji mais d'une manière privée et ce
qui lui permettait d'avoir une grande
liberté pour aider les institutions
scolaires dans différents pays
particulièrement d'afrique où il a
beaucoup beaucoup aidé sa vie à costumes
non seulement aider des personnes mais à
corriger des inégalités sociales plus
possible à combler les écarts entre les
favoriser les défavorisés dans la
société
en tout des hommes des femmes entre les
pôles et les riches entre le nord et le
sud s'étaient c'est et ça c'est la vie
de paul se dire s'il y avait une 36e lui
c'était la hantise des talents qui ne se
développait pas des mozart qui ne lui
est pas des plus de kiné qui lui va pas
pour terminer les funérailles seront
jeudi demain jeudi
votre sentiment à la veille
des funérailles de paul gérin de paul
gérin lajoie pas que j'aurai la joie et
identifient à l'idée que l'éducation est
une priorité nationale ça dans les
années 60 c'est pas que j'allais la joie
qui affirmer ça et et il était le
symbole de cette idée mais aujourd'hui
l'éducation n'est pas une priorité
nationale il faut bien le reconnaître
nous avons une société vieillissante qui
se préoccupe de sa santé ou qui se
préoccupe de ce décès de son système
routier ou ou bien sûr de la planète
s'est pas trop mal mais mais mais
l'avenir sinon la jeunesse l'avenir d'un
système d'éducation
l'éducation devrait être une priorité
nationale constant permanente
cette seule projet de pôle général a
joué à ça des gammes de la molécule et
c'est guy rocher merci beaucoup
[Musique]